B-but...why are you leaving?
I'm a free agent now
Will you be back?
Yes, one way or another
Your Stashe Brother Steven will look after you now
You will be in good hands...dlebars
She'll be a'right
Well, I must be going now
It's time for me to test the markets
Ya! Ya!
Fare thee well, brothers!
Good on ya, mate!
Farewell Kevin
Now
I do what I want
I know you and Russ had your issues,
but I can assure you
there will be no such chemistry problems here
Well that’s nice to hear
Plus you’ll have the services of the premier
point guard in the realm
Wait, uh, so better than Steph Curry?
Well, certainly top three
Well, there’s Russell and Chris Paul...
Top three point guard...in the East is what I meant
OK um, well then there’s Kyrie Irving--
Kyrie’s gotta be No. 1
and then Kyle Lowry...he’s pretty good these days
And Isaiah Thomas? Honestly underrated--
Shut up Bradley!
Do you want him to play here or not!
Well I’m just being honest!
Oh you want honesty?
I’d be top three EASY if my max contract
shooting guard wasn’t always INJURED
Oh, so sorry John!
I put my body on the line for this team!
(mocking, falsetto): Oh, I’m Bradley! I’m made of glass!
Will you two twits shut up!
(sigh)
As I was saying, uh, the chemistry here...
definitely top five...
in the East
So...uh, what’s that...
what’s that over there? What’s that box?
Soul Box
I’m sorry, you said “soul box”?
Soul box. So...like a box...
for souls?
When you sign with the Spurs
your soul and your personality are put into the box
Riiiiight. So...
do I get it back?
Indubitably
Ha, ha, ha, ha, haaaa
So
What are your thoughts on tankin'?
Oh it’s true
If you were to join us, you’d be endlessly ridiculed,
your old teammates will despise you
and the fans in Oklahoma will cook their stew
on the flames of your burning jersey
People will call you a traitor,
a coward
and some may say you’ve destroyed the entire balance of the realm
But...on the other hand!
If you were to join us, we would be...
so good
Cleveland!
This is for you!
But we will win not just one championship!
Not two!
LeBron, um, sorry, uh...you might want to read this
Can this wait?
Not three!
It concerns some changes next year
If this is about Delly going to the Bucks...I think we’ll live
Not four but...!
Um...But one is fine!
Some people never get championships
And we should be happy with this one
Well we’re all very excited to have you here
But I must warn you, the Garpax has eyes EVERYWHERE
Be careful what you say
and let your game do the talking
Have no doubt,
I’m as healthy as ever AND I shoot threes now
There’s no reason we can’t form a superteam
Is that...is that Dwyane Wade?
—here in Chicago
Oh Seven Hells
It is. It is you!
Who is that?
Someone you know?
Mario Chalmers
We used to play together in Miami
Oh great, here we go
Hello Rio
Nooooo
You’re on the Bulls now?
Oh that’s so WEIRD
We was on a superteam together
“The Big Four!”
‘Member those days, Dwyane?
...no?
But I can’t blame you for leaving really
Twilight-a your career...
bad knees, bad shoulders...
maybe you can scrape together one last playoff run with...
sorry what’s your name?
Jimmy Butler
Oh
You DO look a lot like Michael Jordan
Well it’s all very exciting
We must be going now, I’m afraid
Oh. Alright, um, well,
if you need a point guard
or whatever...
just, send me a raven, yeah?
We have Rondo
Oh well,
you never know with him
He’s a bit...
(crazy whistle)
You’ll definitely need a veteran backup, no?
We have plenty of depth but we’ll keep you in mind
Cause...you know,
we could be a superteam again!
Bye Rio!
YOU CAN YELL AT ME ALL YOU LIKE
I DON’T MIND!
Alright, well...
guess I’ll head to Cleveland
Gadzooks!
Come in, come in!
I came to say hello and welcome you to Houston
Ah! Why thank you!
And you must be the new scouting apprentice!
I’ve been expecting you
Uh...I’m your starting shooting guard...
James Harden?
All Realm shooting guard?
James... James... you say...
one moment please!
Aha!
James Harden!
The point guard. Forgive me.
Shooting guard--
I’ve been studying your game...
it’s marvelous. Brilliant really!
Oh, that’s very kind of you to say...
So you...have a lot of books, I see
This whole shelf is... inbound plays?
Ah yes...
baseline, sideline...
I also keep iso plays in there somewhere
for no good reason really
And this shelf here,
all books on the art of the pass
Wow!
Over there, that's tempo plays, pick and rolls...
you name it!
Feel free to borrow them as you please, by the way
Wow
I bet you need whole new library just for all
defensive plays
Hmm?
Defense...like...you know
when the other team has the ball?
...And they try to...you know...score...
on... us?
Oh no no no. None of that here
It’s a waste of energy and it’s no fun
I say
half the defense...
double the offense!
Five minutes, Melo
Understood
Ser Oakley
Carmelo...
seems you’re my last friend in Knicks colors
Quite the opposite, actually
The whole city cheers your name
outside these Garden walls
I saw what they did to you
More like what I did to them
It’s not right
You’re a legend
I’m just an old enforcer
When I saw how the front office was treating you...
well...
I did what I’ve always done...
I stand up for our best players
’Specially against the twonks
who run this house these days
Well I’m here to return the favor
Now c’mon, we don’t have much time
Whaddya mean?
Whaddya doin’?
We’re getting you out of here
Wait...who’s “we”?
(Whistle)
Derrick! The key!
Toss it now!
Huh?
Joakim?
Where’s Derrick?
He had to go
He had family issues
What?
Well do you have the key?
Uh huh, yeah...
Well then toss it!
Right, right. Okay, sure
Oh crap
Men!
Do you hear that?
It’s game time!
YEAH!
It’s early, for sure,
but if the season ended today,
we’d barely be in the eighth seed
Do you want to be in the eighth seed?
No!
Aye!
No, Thad, we don’t want that
Ayyyyyye DON’T want the eighth seed
I don’t want that...
We are the Pacers of Indiana!
We don’t settle for the eighth seed
No!
Would Ser Reggie Miller have settled for the eighth seed?
Would Jermaine of Neal have settled for the eighth seed?
No!
Probably not!
Would...
M-Mark Jackson or...
Rik Smits have settled for the eighth seed?
Maybe?
Who is Rip Smith?
We are not an eighth seed team!
Better than that!
We will not be a seventh seed team!
Well, we probably will be though
What I see, is MUCH better than our record
I see a...
fifth or sixth seed team!
Probably seventh
Who will at BEST make it to the second round
FIRST!
But probably no further!
YEAH
I’M OKAY WITH THAT!
Right now,
our defense is 25th in the league
Let's get that up to 15th!
Yeah!
And our offense...it’s 20th!
Boo!
Let's inch that up to maybe also 15!
15!
So let’s go out there
and send those Pistons back to Detroit
and fulfill our destiny!
To have a decent regular season
and a forgettable playoffs!
YEAH!
What is going on?
Shhh....it’s the trade deadline
This could be our ticket out of here
Why would you want to leave?
Aren’t we in line for the first pick?
No, we’re not!
Because that fool Billy King traded it to
Boston a few years ago!
What!?
I know! They’re idiots--
Der coming! Der coming!
Back up, back up!
Everybody back up!
I’m sorry to announce...
we have made a trade
Oh yes oh yes
Please please please
Bojan
Yeah
You’re going to Washingfell
Sorry
Oh my god!
They are like, uh...
They have like...wins
Yes
Thirty-four wins, they have
THIRTY-FOUR?!
Oh man, that’s like so many wins!
I know you’re disappointed, but...
pack your bags
They expect you there on the morrow
Right. Right. Oh yeah I’m very sad
This is so--I’m very sad but I’ll go pack now
and fight all the tears
Um...love all you guys!
Thanks, uh, Lord Commander--ex-Lord Commander!
Oh this is so sad!
This is SO GOOD! OH I’M FREE!
I’M FREE FROM THIS PIECE OF SHIT TEAM!
THIS IS THE HAPPIEST DAY OF MY LIFE!
I DON’T HAVE TO BE IN STUPID BROOKLYN
THIS IS THE DUMBEST PLACE
WORST FRANCHISE  EVER!
MAN THESE GUYS ARE F--
Any..uh...other trades to report? Or...
No
Dammit!
Now, come on, it's time to practice
Tomorrow we lose to the Nuggets!
Who goes there?
House Magic!
What are they doing here?
We don’t play ‘em for a fortnight
What do you want?
We want to propose a trade!
Well we don’t need a trade.
We’re contenders!
Oh come on now, you’re fifth in the East!
You’re worse than the...Hawks right now!
Don’t you want to compete with the Cavs?
I mean, It’s true
We could use, like, a power forward
Well then do it! Do it! Do it!
Well alright, whaddya got?
Serge Ibaka!
He shoots, dunks, and he’s an elite rim protector.
He’s everything you need
Isn’t that right Serge?
I defend anyone
Except LeBron
Alright. Okay
Well what do you want for him?
DeMar DeRozan!
No! He’s my friend!
Argh. Very well
Worth a shot
Then give us...
Norman Powell!
No!
He's...too young!
But I’m also your friend, right?
Shush Norman!
I'm trying to make a trade here!
I am also his friend!
Norman!
Alright. Well then what else do you have to offer?
We’ll give you...
Can we trade Drake?
I don’t think so. No
What about Terrence?
What about Terr--
You can have Terrence Ross
Well what does he do?
He’s like...
an older Norman
No I’m not
Terrence! You’ll like it in Orlando. It’s warm
Let the man speak!
Terrence, what do you do?
Well, I’m a pretty good 3 and D player...
Um...
though some people might call me inconsistent...
So maybe I’m not a good 3 and D player--
No no no, you are!
I AM a good 3 and D player
OH! And a decorated dunker!
Well he’s certainly inconsistent
Throw in a draft pick and it’s a deal!
A draft pi--
Fine, but then you gotta give us somethin’ else too!
Something else? Ugh
Alright we’ll give you a choice
You can either have...Mario Hezonja...
Or...this horse
Well what does Mario do?
He scores three points a game
And what does the horse do?
It’s a f-- it’s a horse!
It walks around with people on it
I don’t know...does horse things!
That kid was the fifth pick in the draft.  He's probably got potential.
Yeah but it's a horse! It does horse things!
We’ll take the horse!
Well, look who it is
the Brow...and the Foul
Just ignore them. They’re trying to get under your skin
Aww...how cute is that, Enes
Look at them
They’re like closer than his eyebrows!
Looks like Boogie Cousins has a Boogie Brother
I don’t know though, I’m a bit scared
I mean, with this chemistry they’ve got?
I think they’ve got a real shot at the 10th seed
You know, you talk a lot for someone who has less rebounds than his point guard
Keep your focus, DeMarcus
If you get a technical, you’ll be suspended again
I’m sorry. We’re being rude
I’m actually a big admirer of your game
I love da move where you fake left, roll right, and then get ejected
You know for being a big, whiney pu--
I’ll knock that fancy little stache so far down your throat
you’ll have a merkin on your entrails
Hey hey! Stop it! Stop it! It’s not worth it!
He’s right. Enough of this
King of the Prairie!
While we’re bickering over eyebrows and mustaches,
Golden State is marching towards the championship
Save your energy for the real fight
ARGH! FINE!
To hell with Golden State!
Technical foul!
Oh, c’mon! You gotta be kiddin’ me, ref! For what?
Uh, disembowelment of a referee
which the league is sort of crackin’ down on now...
Do you like it here...in Dallas?
Very much so
Better than Golden State?
Golden State is a ​very​ special place
dear to my heart
But I’m very happy here
in my​ new ​home
But don’t you miss being a contender?
I have a much larger role here
thanks to the graciousness of our Lord
Ah! Nerlens!
I almost didn’t recognize you without your cylindrical hair
It is an honor to present my king
Lord Mark of House Mavericks
Kiss me, child
Thank you, Harrison
We’re delighted to have you here
Please, sit!
Would you like a rib?
No thank you, I’m not very hungry
Oh, child. You can’t come to Texas and not enjoy some ​barbeque​!
Okay
You like the ribs?
It’s very good
They’re Chandler Parsons
...favorite thing to eat when he was here
Oh, you must be thirsty
Where’s the sweet tea?
WHERE’S THE SWEET TEA?
Well don’t just stand there, you imbecile!
Get the DAMN sweet tea!
Now, I know things were...difficult for you in Philadelphia
I’m very grateful for my time at House Sixers--
Oh, stop it
It’s ​dreadful​ in that chamber pot of a franchise
Now, come on
you can be honest with me
I’m not like those other owners, you know
I’m a cool guy
Just a normal
cool
guy
Noted
Well, if I’m being honest
there were a lot of centers and not enough minutes
Frankly, I was very sick of losing
There there, child!
There’s no need to worry anymore
Here in Dallas, we ​never​ tank
Now, chin up!
Aren’t you excited to play with Dirk?
Oh yes, he’s...very good
He’s the greatest
Yeah...he’s great
The greatest
The...greatest
You see, Nerlens
I personally ensure that no one makes light of my Mavericks
Or else...
Or else...what?
Ah! My sweet tea!
Trust the process!
He is close, my lord
Excellent, thank you
Burn the witch!
Fire Sam now!
I don't want more picks
I wanna win!
I wanna be in the playoffs!
Off wif his head!
You suck!
You lied to us!
There's no process!
You're just a loser!
It's time, Sam!
I just need a moment!
They say an analytics man doesn’t have a heart
But I ran the numbers,
and nothing could be further from the truth
You are a son to me, Joel
Know that I will always be watching you
I will always believe in you
Please, forgive me for leaving
I have no choice
Sam, open the door
You will be the light that pulls this city from the darkness
The fruits of the process will soon ripen,
and the harvest will yield
great things
Open the damn door, Hinkie!
Get the battering ram!
And no matter what
you must always
ALWAYS
TRUST THE PROCESS
Remember! Make sure they hold on to
Robert Covington!
Get your hands off me!
Always take the best player available!
Hey, be careful with the lottery spheres!
Every pick has value!
Maintain the long view!
Value optionality!
You suck, Colangelo
Bring back Sam now!
Your maester staff is terrible
Hinkie died for our sins!
Fire the Colangelos!
Ugh, these damn Philadelphia fans
Always so angry
They should be grateful!
I got a first-round pick for Nerlens!
Okay fine, top-18 protected, but Sam always said–
Oh dear, the fanlings have breached the castle walls
It’s going to be fine, father
Okafor is guarding the door
Holdin’ the door
hold the door
hol’ dadoor
oka door
oka foor
Okafor
Okafor!
That’s my n–
Draft Markelle Fultz!
GO FOR THE HOAGIES! GO FOR THE HOAGIES!
Yo, watch it man, you’re spilling my water ice!
Agholor can't even catch
Oh yo, look at this! Hey guys! Embiid’s on the table
Yo! Paint a picture with me and Embiid, yo right here
Good evening!
As reigning realm champions and, with that,
Eastern Conference champions,
we welcome the representatives from each
of the Eastern playoff Houses,
to the annual Feast of the East,
to kick off this year’s playoffs. So please, feast!
Oh my god, look at this,
there’s like so many wings!
I hope Terrence is happy
I know Dwane Casey was pretty pissed that we took the horse
He scares me. Look at those hands. They're huge!
My mentality is you just gotta take it one game at a time
I mean, I just try to leave 110% on the court
Pass me the pigeon pie!
Hey! ...Hey!
What are you staring at?
Is there a pot of gold behind me?
Is there a shamrock in my teeth?
No, I’m just looking at the second-best team in the East
Oh snap
Big balls for such a small man
...DWARF
Oooh
Yeah, yeah, I’ve heard it all before
He’s too short. He can’t play defense
Hell, he isn’t even the best Isiah Thomas
But somehow, this dwarf’s been scoring 30 points a game,
hitting clutch shots,
and House Celtics owns the No. 1 seed
When this tournament’s over,
you’re all gonna look UP at me,
and you’ll know…
there’s a new King in the East!
This again? Didn’t we do this last year?
We’ve got the chemistry and the defense to take you down
Don’t sleep on the two seed my dear King,
for the North will soon rule the East
We are the New Kings of the East!
This again? Didn’t we do this last year?
60 wins. Count ‘em
It puts us in the one seed, and our house goes 12 men deep
We are the Spurs of the East
Tell ‘em Korverbird
*HAWK SCREECH* TEAM BASKETBALL!
This year, there will be a NEW KING OF THE EAST!
We’re doing this again?
You’re on your last leg, LeBron
We’re coming for you
There will be a new king in the East
And this time I MEAN IT
OK, Paul, you literally did this last year
The era of Paul George,
of Roy Hibbert and House Pacers begins now!
Verticality!
There will be a new KING IN THE EAST!
We’re doing this a--
They say your superteam can’t be beat,
but we got the original Big Three and I say…
ANYTHING IS POSSIBLE
KG was wrong
It's not true
Nothing is possible
Th-there's no point in trying
Le-LeBron wins the East every year
We should all be tanking
The playoffs are a trap!
They're gonna beat us all!
It's a trap!
We've gotta get out of here!
GET OUT!
GO TANK!
GO TANK FOR THE FUTURE!
[Sensual Dornish music]
Playing in the paint, I see
It's my favorite place to draw fowls
Why are you still here?
I thought your bannermen left long ago
Do you think they can make it home
without you to carry them?
[Sensible chuckle]
How about a quick duel, James? One on one
Just like old times
I don't have time for your games, Brodie
Some of us are still in the playoffs
You're right. I'd hate to break those
SECOND most valuable ankles before your next series
Ay! You come into my casa with so much sass-a
Do your worst, bitch!
Mmm, very nice!
A double Shammgod into The Answer’s crossover
Impressive
Actually, that was Tim Hardaway's
Oh, sorry
I was supposed to let you get the rebound, right?
Now this move here, I used it for my 22nd triple-double
Ha! I used this one for my 42nd
I don’t know why you don’t come to Houston more often
You clearly love to travel
Oh this from a man who leads the league in turnovers?
Not anymore!
Game point, James
Time to show off those renowned defensive skills
Ah, but actually, my defense is much improved!
In fact, if you look at the numbers,
you will see that I contested over EIGHT shots per game,
Third most among guards—
Aw, MOTHER FOYLE!
We could've had it all, James
If you and the Serpent hadn’t slithered away
OK, Russ. Like this isn’t what you wanted ALL along
To finally be the MAN
All the triple-doubles, the Realm MVP...
Now he does what he wants, right?
...Everything except win
Now if you’ll excuse me
I have to get my ass kicked by the Spurs
And get his ass kicked, they did
Though Ser Beard and his bannermen won the first battle,
House Spurs proved too strong,
vanquishing House Rockets in six games
Elsewhere in the West,
House Warriors made quick work of the Brotherhood with One Banner
and sent House Jazz to a swift demise
When the Pop King and his Soulless Army tried to stop them,
they found silver was no match for gold
Over in the East,
the Hammer of Akron smashed rebellions from House Pacers and the Canadlings
All eyes turned to the one seed,
but the King of the Fourth proved merely
the King of Fourth Place
And so it was written
King James and the Champions of Balleros
against the most powerful house the Realm has ever seen
OK, well maybe second
Second?! Who's first?
Well, obviously it's Ser Jordan and his 96 Bulls
Well, some say it's the Bulls, but others argue
it's the Showtime Dynasty right here in Los Angeles!
How do we become a dynasty again, Lord Magic?
I want to become a dynasty!
Well, the first step is to trade all the little buggers who send inappropriate ravens
Harumph!
Then, we sign big-time free agents
Like Paul George!
And thirdly, we build through the DRAFT
Yesss! From the fire you are born, my little Lonzo
The Triad of Balls will make the Realm shake
Go forth, and get us our ONE BILLION gold
WAAAAHHHH!!! I want to play for the Lakers, Daddy!
THAT'S MY BOY! MUHAHAHA!
HAHAHAHA!
HAHAHAHAAAA!